[Musique]
souffrir pour être fin quand on pense
aux femmes du mali
on pense à nouveau roubaix
alors votez qui est légendaire à la joie
de vivre
mais alors pourquoi souffrir pour être
fin je vais voir histoire de trois
filles la première je vous laisse
imaginer fille de 4 ans elle vit dans un
village
elle joue avec ses amis et un beau jour
elle se fait vous fait arracher par une
de ses tantes une de ses grands-pères
peut-être menées dans un lieu qu'elle
ignore naïve elle les suit bien
évidemment sans savoir ce qu'il a dans
et là elle va rejoindre d'autres
fillettes
imaginez le tableau plusieurs fillettes
entre 4 et 6 ans installé dans un lieu
qu'elle ignore et là elle va subir l'une
des premières violences de sa vie on va
lui couper une de ces parties
on va lui couper une de ses parties
intimes et là dans toute la douleur
qu'elle ressent elle essaye de se lever
elle essaye de marché elle essaie de
trouver une solution pour amoindrir ses
douleurs qu'elle ne comprend pas
d'ailleurs
et là on lui dit certes des gens certes
des dents car tu enfin femme doit
souffrir et la sortie de ce traumatisme
physique et morale elle continue les
corvées d'eau les corvées de bois
elle va pas à l'école parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'énergie à la maison elle doit
aider sa maman dans les travaux
domestiques et là un beau jour
à la puberté à peine vient-elle de
devenir pape qu'elle doit se marier et
là encore c'est l'inconnu un mari
qu'elle ne connaît pas dans kiss qui
serait d'un villages avoisinants qui
serait probablement beaucoup plus âgés
ou encore de son âge elle doit le
rejoindre
et là après tout les festivités on lui
donne un conseil très simple tu vas chez
son mari c'est ta mère c'est dieu sur
terre tu fais tout ce qu'ils te
demandent sans tuer en dur tout ce qu'il
te fais car tu es une femme tu dois
souffrir
et là c'est parti si les bleus
sera battu si c'est un psychopathe
hasard peut faire qui sera peut-être
clément avec elle mais c'est l'inconnu
et là elle va faire des enfants dans ce
corps qui n'est pas encore développée il
n'y a pas de centre de santé
elle pourra perdre des bébés elle pourra
elle même place
et là je ne vous raconte plus son
histoire parce que vous connaissez la
suite
et à une deuxième fille qui fuit le
mariage précoce elle n'a pas échappé à
l'excision mais elle refuse de marier
cet homme qu'elle ne connaît pas hélas
celle aventure et vient dans la ville
c'est l'inconnu elle va être employé
dans une famille est là elle va subir
encore des violences mais elle sera en
dur et que c'est une femme et elle
pourrait être violenté et un jour si un
bijou se perd dans cette maison elle va
se retrouver en détention préventive
dans le centre de détention pour femmes
et mineurs et elle pourra y rester des
années personne ne vient chercher car
elle a fui le mariage précoce car elle
n'a plus de parents pour cette raison et
la société n'a aucun égard pour cette
fille et son histoire est terminée
il y aura plus de suite pour elle elle
aurait pu aussi contracté une grossesse
précoce dans toute cette errance dans la
ville qui lui est inconnu
s'emparant son soutien sans aucune loi
qui la protègent comment y la police
dénoncer un viol qu'il écoutera qui va
la sortir de ces rafles nocturnes entre
les mains de la police personne
c'est une femme elle va souffrir alors
j'ai
à relancer mesdames et messieurs quand
vous sortirez 18 vous allez voir les
vendeuse de bananes les vendeuses dos
les aides ménagères les vendeuses de
brochettes regarder quelle valeur
ajoutée
elle apporte à notre économie il faut
absolument
je m'adresse à vous aujourd'hui et j'ai
des paniers de colas derrière pour mes
pairs dont je m'excuse auprès desquels
je m'excuse il faut qu'on arrête de
penser que les hommes sont supérieurs
aux femmes il faut que les hommes
acceptent de partager leur super
puissance avec les femmes il faut
absolument changer le regard des hommes
et de ce système patriarcal de notre
société car après vingt ans de lutte
contre l'excision
comment pouvez vous imaginer que le mali
en 2017 à 89 % de taux de prévalence
c'est révoltant comment comprendre
aujourd'hui que le mariage précoce
persiste que des filles se marient à 11
comment allons-nous continuer à ne pas
promouvoir la scolarisation des filles
mais de manière concrète que chaque
homme s'investissent pour sa fille que
chaque homme s'investissent pour
sensibiliser nos pères dans les villages
pour éduquer les filles pour les éviter
de venir en ville
vendeuse ambulante pour subir des
violences et par les lois pour être
oublié par un système et surtout il faut
aborder le problème sous un angle
économique
comment voulez vous que notre croissance
s'améliore si la moitié de la population
ne participa à la création de la régie
cesse parce que toutes ces filles qui
viennent en vie est ce que vous imaginez
que leur seule ambition c'est de venir
acheter quelques habits retourner se
marier et c'est terminé
elle ne pue pas à la création de la
richesse dans aujourd'hui le problème
d'inégalité de genre au mali
c'est le problème de notre sous
développement et ça les hommes il va
vraiment falloir y faire face et mais
avant tout tout tout ce que je vous
demande d'abord de faire c'est de cesser
toute forme de vie pensent mais surtout
de vous investir dans l'éducation de vos
filles de ne pas dire à vos free and on
and on va voir ta maman ça n'est pas mon
problème
non tout problème du tpi concerne autant
la maman que le papa et plus les papas
s'investissent dans l'éducation dans la
surveillance dans la protection de la
fille mieux elle sera protégée
donc les hommes je vous interpelle
changer votre regard accepté de partager
le pouvoir
comment voulez vous qu'on se développe à
l'assemblée nationale on à 147 députés
dont l'infâme c'est anti démocratique
tout simplement il ya 52 % de femmes
n'ai pas peur de partager le pouvoir
avec les femmes n'ayez pas peur de ne
plus être les dieu sur terre et d'avoir
aussi des femmes qui sont là qui
travaillent à vos côtés et donc je vais
vous parler maintenant de la troisième
fille elle par contre elle est allée à
l'école elle a fait des études elle n'a
pas subi de violences parce que c'est
son père qui l'a protégé avance sa merde
avant tout les femmes qu'elle
connaissait
c'est son père qui l'a poussé à faire
des études supérieures
c'est encore son père qui lui a fait
comprendre que la tradition elle est
importante que la religion elle est
important mais ce qui est important
avant tout c'est la vie humaine c'est
l'être humain est dans sa nous sommes
tous égaux et il n'y a aucune limite au
potentiel de la fille par rapport aux
garçons
alors cette fille elle elle a grandi
elle elle a choisi son mari elle a fait
des enfants elle est épanouie dans sa
vie mais elle l'a été tout simplement
parce que dans sa vie elle a été protégé
des violences parce que dans sa vie on
lui a donné les mêmes opportunités que
les garçons et 7 filles
mesdames et messieurs c'est moi
et c'est moi et c'est grâce à mon père
et il sait pas pourquoi je lui ai dit de
venir aujourd'hui c'est ça que je
voulais lui dire je le remercie et g je
vous fais peur les uns est ce que je
fais peur vous pensez que les femmes qui
vont à l'école qui travaillent qui qui
sont manager qui manage des hommes on
n'attrape pas le sac de notre mari quand
il rentre à la maison
monsieur drame elle il pourra vous dire
si c'est vrai ou pas et puis d'ailleurs
pourquoi les hommes notre après pas le
sac des femmes ce serait bien
tout simplement pour vous dire qu'il
n'ya pas de raid avoir peur des femmes
qui sont ambitieuses ou des femmes qui
ont le pouvoir et de l'est pas peur que
nous allons en fait inverser la tendance
j'entends ça souvent il n'y a aucune
raison que cela arrive mais il faut
vraiment comprendre que les questions de
gens ce n'est pas les femmes
le problème du genre le problème de
discrimination et inégalités dans notre
pays est la première cause de notre
pauvreté
aujourd'hui et tant qu'on ne va pas
régler cela la moitié de la population
ne pourra pas développer le mali sans
l'autre moitié est donc j'aimerais
aujourd'hui dire autre chose et là j'ai
encore des paniers de colas pour mme et
mr il est temps d'arrêter de perpétuer
des traditions qui nous font souffrir ma
fille vient de voir en te disant elle a
été battue par son mari
tu lui dis moi j'ai vu pire retour
ta fille aînée un peu chétif quand même
lui faire subir l'excision pourquoi et
donc je crois que en bambara andy
domaniale adveniat cheylard aulas il
faut aussi qu en tant que femmes nous
prenons notre responsabilité pour sortir
de la tude infériorité pour sortir en
fait de ce système qui fait de nous des
victimes et que nous même à certains
moments perpétuant parce que la violence
je vous dis elle peut causer la violence
est le premier frein à tout
développement et l'épanouissement de la
femme et de la vie et donc à nous aussi
les femmes nous avons notre partition à
jouer et donc j'invite vraiment top
dans cette salle a changé votre regard
sur les filles mais a changé votre
regard sur toutes les filles vous allez
sortir vous allez c'est elle le mali
quand des 52% de la population et
féminin elle à moins de 15 ans et elle
n'est pas loin elle est là elle ne
contribue pas à créer de la richesse
elle ne rapporte aucune valeur ajoutée
est temps que ça se passera ainsi on ne
se développera pas mais avant tout est
là
ce sont toutes formes de violence et de
discrimination à l'endroit des femmes et
des filles et cessant de perpétuer ces
pratiques traditionnelles néfastes qui
ne nous permettent pas d'avancer
aujourd'hui je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]